we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about we've
got new crossfit white-eyed surf set
cardio mission in boot camp it's your
body
I am Noah and I and I got into boot camp
because it works it's efficient it's fun
it tests your limits and it makes you
stronger as a person so boot camp has
origins in the army it was a method to
train soldiers and it was also a method
to assess fitness as I've trained Navy
SEALs before and I claimed Marines
I trained probably 145 people a day but
as a trainer my philosophy is I want to
return you to your strong kind of
hunter-gatherer state where you feel
like you can go out and accomplish tasks
we have the music thumping and the red
lights are on and the Energy's there and
that's all all of that is to make you
move your body how I think that you
should move in if you want to look hard
and feel hard you train hard so that's
what we do we go hard
here's the bootcamp report now so Eric
here's my victim we're gonna run him
through the wringer right now so Eric
you ready I think so
so now we're never taught now or never
so we're gonna start with a simple it's
been around forever started with Roman
times the clean and the press it's a
full body workout so what we're gonna do
is right here we're gonna grab this bar
make sure our hands are nice and wide I
don't want to close grip okay I'm gonna
keep my chest tall we're gonna roll this
up snatch our wrist then keeping a nice
wide base all that weights in our heels
exhale it up then slowly bring it down
so we're gonna break that down into a
component move so what we're gonna do
after that
we're gonna do that after that 45
seconds we're gonna bring this down
right into that chest we're gonna switch
our grips safely right here right on his
shoulders we're gonna look high again so
we don't lean forward weights in our
heels we're gonna hip back all that
weight snarky else we're gonna hip
forward taking it right to a front
loaded squat so now is when we really
start to play with body weight go into
the split pulse lunge so what we're
gonna do knee is over that heel we're
gonna look straight and tall chest as
high we're gonna pulse one two one two
three now let's finish it off so push up
we're gonna leave with that chest but it
wouldn't be my discipline if we just did
a normal push-up that's slightly that's
old-school
we want that 2013 sauna feeling and kind
of body so right here we're gonna keep
our chest nice and in alignment right
here nice flat back tap that chest
exhale
to a push-up exhale
so tell me you don't have three minutes
to do this full workout let's get it
you're on the stopwatch time has started
let's go 45 seconds
I need controlled chaos so at home if
you don't have access to a wake you can
always grab any form of weight you can
grab your cat milk jugs you wrap water
jugs you wrap anything so now we're
gonna turn this right into a front
loaded squat so right here let's bring
those hips back so that your knees are
over those heels let's try to make sure
that those knees are further back watch
there yeah I got you we're going for
that spa Singh split yah yah yah yah
this is the kicker this is the metabolic
in there I know right here so we're
gonna pulse 1 2 off that heel then
switch it up 1 2 3 so let's take it to
the floor now proper push-up position
let's get a strong pillar wrist elbow
shoulder bring those shoulder blades
back squeezing one more even it out cool
you ready to hit that bootcamp class now
yeah I got to work on this yeah
so if you're intimidated by bootcamp
classes or group classes in general
here's your path home workout to kind of
dip your toes in the water we have 45
seconds of that pain and press we have
45 seconds of that front squat then your
other 45 seconds is a snap pulsing split
lunch then to cap that off we're gonna
get off those legs and do the push-up
plank adding that toe touch it make sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any other fighting weight episodes